katie is in Lubbock Texas hi Katie
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show how are
you better than I deserve how can I help
okay I have a question on life insurance
and my husband is 16 and we took that
life insurance probably when he was 64
the premium is 210 dollars a month and
it's term life I got laid off from my
job so I'm not working and I just want
to see if we're still making a live
decision on paying that amount I'm just
as salary mm-hmm so what does he make I
think that's about 70 okay and are you
guys have children at home still no no
okay
and do you have a home that has got a
mortgage no pay for it's paid for okay
how much is in your nest egg for
retirement because of bad decisions when
we were younger virtually nothing inside
about sixty thousand all right so what
are you planning on living on that
retirement well hopefully I'm going to
get another job and look in as soon as I
see the 64 thing app it gets kind of
tossed but I'm still looking and
thinking about maybe doing something on
my own so are y'all saving for
retirement and your husband's income
yeah we are but we still have about
fifteen thousand dollars in debt and so
we're trying to yeah we're trying to
tand on each and that really show what
time is that if you go we've got about
fifteen thousand dollars in credit cards
to pay you cut them up oh we don't yeah
to large budget oh yes we do every
dollar so how quickly is a fifteen
thousand will be paid off probably we're
thinking our December
I hope yeah yeah good okay and then you
guys are going to move on and get your
emergency fund inflation
stack up as everything you can into
retirement as fast as you can yeah wide
open okay what's your homework oh gosh
probably about a hundred okay how much
life insurance is on him 200 okay how
much is on you okay yeah I believe I
keep the insurance in place it's there
to replace his income if something
happens to him and you would still need
that you don't have any money you got a
paid-for house and you'll be debt-free
soon but you're any money right yeah I'm
gonna keep it for a while but as soon as
you've got 200,000 or 300,000 saved
which you ought to have in a few years
here you might want to look at dropping
it at that point okay
the point is are you okay financially
when he dies if you have a paid-for
house and three or four hundred thousand
dollars saved you probably okay okay
that's great I just want to make sure
that we're not doing something really
stupid right now
no you're not you're not but you're
gonna have to play catch-up here you
need to get on the you get on the horse
and kick him hard okay I'm gonna send
you a copy of Ken Coleman's book the
proximity principle the proven way to
find the career that you love and you're
in the process of a job hunt and a
career adjustment yourself and they'll
help you with that so hold on